the man himself is on the phone to give
us an update on his life and everything
that's going on with him Roger stone
Roger
welcome to Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
delighted to be back with you gentlemen
I'm delighted to have you Roger
the things that they've been saying
about you on my TV set recently they've
got me very very worried you know we
always there's been this floating thing
about indictments and criminal charges
and whatnot about you for quite some
time however it seems like within the
last week or so things have picked up to
a fever pitch well you know the only
thing worse than being talked about of
course is not being talked about yes
although in this case I might take
exception to my own rule I was on with
George Stephanopoulos who's very short
by the way how tall is George
Stephanopoulos I gret that great
physical joke you said had it up to here
with him I think I know doesn't work on
radio so any event we had a very good
show but what's amazing is I said the
exact same things that I said to Chuck
Todd on Meet the Press almost a year ago
and everybody acted like it was no this
is really simple no I never received
anything including allegedly hacked or
allegedly stolen emails from WikiLeaks
or Julian Assange no I never passed any
such materials on to Donald Trump no I
never had any communication with Julian
Assange and the only communication I had
with WikiLeaks was a 24 word exchange on
Twitter direct message in which they
essentially brushed me off which I
turned over to the House Intelligence
Committee well over a year ago so
there's no they're there yet I pick up
the Wall Street Journal Shelby Holliday
the single most dishonest complicitous
sneaky backstabbing lying reporter
working in America today Wow head and
her headlines is more probing contacts
between stone and WikiLeaks
no he isn't because there are none none
so it gets it gets tedious
it's almost like the groundhog movie
right they keep coming back to the same
false charge and it is it does seem to
have a new fever pitch but there's no
there there now there yet you're it's
ironic you're there there is like it
almost sounds like Bill Clinton trying
to figure out what the definition of the
word is is well yesterday it was
revealed that I told both the Senate
Intelligence and the Senate Judiciary
Committee's that I'm not going to turn
over four tractor-trailer loads of
documents and I'm not going to come
testify for them I'm going to invoke my
Fifth Amendment constitutional
protections yes unless they want to let
me testify in public this is where James
Comey I think is actually right why do
we need to do these things behind closed
doors I testified for the House
Intelligence Committee over a year ago
every word of my testimony is true I can
prove it if I need to I'm not even
allowed to have a copy of the transcript
let me ask you this do you wait because
they our president Donald Trump your guy
once said a year or two ago that he said
you know who pleads the fifth is
mobsters and I'm paraphrasing here I'm
not reading the quote but he said
mobsters are the ones that plead the
fifth and he said if you're in it if
you're not guilty why would you plead
the fifth now an answer and the earth
answer is perjury traps and trumped-up
process cards I thought this was about
Russian collusion so here's a perfect
example I go to the House Intelligence
Committee I testify now Adam Schiff who
is perhaps the greatest huckster maybe
the greatest con man and fraud in
American politics today Wow he comes out
and says stone perjured himself before
the committee well let's go through it
one I did reveal to the committee that
the source regarding the significance in
the October timing of the WikiLeaks
disclosures it so destroyed Hillary's
campaign came from Randy cretak Oh a new
york-based
radio talk show host right I remember
that rant and about 10 days ago 12 days
ago I released 80 pages of text messages
that proved indisputably that he was my
source and that his argument that he
could have been my source in late July
of 2016 because he didn't meet Assange
and interview him until late August was
he irrelevant because he admits in his
own words that his source was a woman
lawyer who worked for WikiLeaks so that
part is entirely true now you have the
more recent claims suggested to him by
the Special Counsel office of dr. Jerry
Corsi this is a guy who believes that
moon-landing never happened that did it
I believe it did okay either that it was
shot in a warehouse in New Jersey I'm
not sure which some people had a Kubrick
shot it yeah well I don't think so any
event so but course he comes out they
find an email that he sent me in October
2nd in which he says the WikiLeaks
disclosures are coming they'll be out
next week that was wrong there'll be a
second dump right after that that was
also wrong and he goes on to say the
Podesta's will be exposed to the
American people aha they say there's
proof that stone knew about Podesta's
emails being stolen no it doesn't
doesn't say that at all so everything I
told the committee is correct but
instead of engaging in this frivolous
word splitting the this the Harris you
know the the the hair splitting over
semantics and arguing over non material
[ __ ] let's make this simple if Adam
Schiff like any evidence or proof at all
that I knew about the source or the
content of the WikiLeaks disclosures or
that I received allegedly stolen or
allegedly hacked you must produce it
writes it or shut the [ __ ] up
ouch I watched the George Stephanopoulos
interview and a couple of things struck
me number one I liked when you said that
Mueller was giving you a metaphorical
proctological exam you know meaning you
know he was he was up your ass but
Stephanopoulos didn't pop for that one
he didn't go with you on that
which I thought was it was a great line
I thought it was great and you snuck it
in on ABC like who does that on network
TV I thought it was wonderful but I
think but I do think people need to
understand what it means yes tell me I
now I'm now gotten now going into two
and a half years of being under the
microscope true that that is yeah
because I was under surveillance in 2016
New York Times reported on January 20th
2017 that I was one of three people
being surveilled by the Obama
administration during the election long
before Robert Muller was even appointed
what's that about what's the probable
cause for that other than the fact that
I was supporting and was an advisor to
Donald Trump and then the two years
since mr. Muller came to town they have
literally poked through every single
aspect of my life my personal life my
social life my family life my business
life my political life my sex life but
my drinking habits whether I like to
smoke a doob now in that I mean what
does any of this have to do with Russian
collusion I think you guys know Kristin
Davis a very of course out pal of mine
why would FBI agents be taking pictures
of her of her infant son and showing
people saying is Roger stone the father
of this baby are you what does it have
to do I'm not oh I love that kid I'm a
godfather to that baby and I love him
dearly but I'm not his daddy okay what
does this have to do with Russian
collusion I mean FBI agents have we're
seen ruffling through my garbage
FBI agents questioned my cleaning lady I
thought this was about Russian collusion
between or collusion between the
Russians maybe you told the cleaning
lady
hey don't those that stack of papers
over there don't throw those out I got
those from WikiLeaks that's Russian
Kaiser she would have understood it in
anyway because I don't speak Spanish I
see okay all right well that actually
makes sense then but on the
Stephanopoulos show he aired the clip I
think it's from a couple years ago you
were talking in front of a group of
people and your quote and you explained
the quote so I'm not asking you to
explain the quote again unless you want
to of course you're free to but your
quote was quote it guys saw it I would
amazed when I saw it it came right out
of your mouth you said the sentence I
have communicated with Julian Assange so
can I have correct and I've corrected it
89 times do you regret saying that
because it does it does when you hear
that quo no and then you hear you say
that you have not communicated with
Julian Assange I think that's when
people get all hung up on the Roger
stone lying thing here's that here's the
clarification yeah I said within 24
hours of that my communication was
through an intermediary brandy credit
though I said it under oath on the
record in front of the House
Intelligence Committee I've said it in a
dozen interviews George knew that but he
didn't mention that plan kind of like oh
you were in touch with Lucifer 2.0 and
he was a Russian hacker yes we had a 24
word exchange over Twitter direct
messages but they don't mention to you
is the content of the exchange is
innocuous there's nothing in there that
constitutes collaboration or collusion
but more precisely it took with it took
place six weeks after WikiLeaks had
already published the documents so
unless I had a time machine and Putin
has not given me his time machine I see
it would be chronologically impossible
to collude with the value of the
publication of something that had
already come out six weeks previously
therefore based on content context and
timing the exchange with Lucifer 2.0
whoever that is is meaningless but then
won't read that in The Wall Street
Journal they recycled that chestnut
again last week so I'm looking last
night I first I see all this
Stephanopoulos on YouTube and I watch
that and that's what I was talking to
you about then I click on this other
thing and it's it's this jerome corsi
and they said to this guy they go
did you help Roger stone lie about
collusion and he says this yes I did and
I go what that's it's totally against
everything Roger stone told me I don't
understand yeah he's a 72 year old man
who it was under under 140 hours of
interrogation by mullahs people and that
is a provable lie he has no evidence
back that up the email traffic the text
traffic all contradict that so Jerry
made up two incredible eyes one he
claimed that my now famous tweet about
the Podesta's was was a that he wrote me
a memo regarding it as a cover story a
cover story for what might wasn't
controversial for six weeks I posted it
there was no social media chatter there
was no media coverage there was no mower
investigation there was no congressional
investigation there was no subpoenas
until Assange published Podesta's email
six weeks later why would I need a cover
story a cover story for what not even
logical it's also untrue and then here's
the best one
ya don't know about the Billy Bush grab
him by the you-know-what tape contacted
me and told asked me to contact Assange
and asked him to move up his disclosures
to distract from that you did that no
exactly exactly nice haha here's the
proof is a phone bill that shows course
he and I had a conversation that Mort
that's it now we also have a
conversation the day before and the day
after that and many many conversations
during 2016 so poor Jerry course he gets
rubber hosed into telling lies about me
and then lastly they said oh and there's
one more thing course he other than been
testifying against stone we need you to
plead to one count that you gave stone
these documents and then he says oh wait
a minute hold on here a second I'm never
gonna lie
so dr. Corsi sadly just not a credible
witness are you mad at this guy this is
a guy you used to talk to on an almost
daily basis and now he's over here how
you say lying about you on television
but whether he's lying or telling the
truth he's not making you look good are
you mad at course he are you pissed
well seventy two years old doing a lot
of drinking heavily
wait wait wait wait Roger
what does how come course he's drinking
is relevant but you're drinking is
irrelevant well because I saw him being
carried out of arrest
see not that long ago he's thinking by
you know and I've never been carried out
at any place I see look III think course
he is a great writer I disagree with him
a lot of stuff I'm disappointed that he
allowed himself to be hot-boxed
by Muller's gumshoes into bearing false
witness against they that's nothing he
says would ever hold up in court because
all the evidence is the contrary he was
perfectly happy to railroad me until he
found out that he was going to have to
do some time and then suddenly he
changed his mind here's the other thing
they were talking about you on CNN - I
watched all these clips and they were
talking about you on CNN and they said
you know your your letter that your
attorney sent out saying that you were
you were the in a vacation or of the
Fifth Amendment saying that you were
taking the Fifth Amendment when your
attorney sent that out he sent that in
response to a request that Senator
Dianne Feinstein had made of you now the
request was not a subpoena meaning you
didn't have to respond to the request a
lot of people have just ignored senator
Feinstein and you could have just
ignored her instead of ignoring her you
chose through your attorney to come out
and make this announcement that you're
pleading the fifth here why not just
ignore this woman because the bulk of
the letter is a demand that any that any
testimony be in public and I'll use any
form I can ice and make that case in
other words there was also a completely
false implication because the president
after my appearance on ABC was Destin
honest put out a tweet in which he said
he placed me for having a lot of guts
because I refuse to make up stories
about him I refused to lie he said that
he loved you because you refused to
testify against him well he's really say
it was a little he said he loved me
because I refused to make up lies and
tell stories to use his exact words some
people wanted to say oh well stones
announcement that he won't testify for
the house partly for the Senate
Judiciary or intelligence committee is a
is a result of Trump's tweet and
therefore that's witness tampering the
problem with that
is I told committees I wouldn't go nor
would I give them anything in advance of
Trump's tweet long before my abc
appearance so again the chronology you
would not learn from CNN look I don't
get my news CNN's for the same reason I
don't eat out of the toilet I see I see
it's just because it's disgusting is
what you're telling me
nowhere near it's just nowhere near the
truth writing it's very sad I mean Don
Lemon demands that I come clean on
Wikileaks I command he take an IQ test I
see I see so your opinion of CNN would
be if somebody were to ingest the news
put it through their entire digestive
system and then move the news through
their bowel what you'd have left would
be CNN in essence CNN is not a news
organization I said it's a it's a
propaganda front I mean I like Anderson
Cooper she's always been very fair with
me he lets me talk I like Chris Cuomo
sometimes he cuts you off and doesn't
let you talk but at least you know you
get your side in but Don Lemon please
give me a break
Don Lemon has always struck me as an
intelligent man you not so much uh no I
think yeah I think he's just a
propagandist you know I mean the big
problem in [ __ ] a big problem in the
country today is white people not Don I
don't think so
I just don't think so well what do you
think would happen if he took an IQ test
what do you think the results would show
I think it'd be rather low okay that's
uh that'd be a bummer for Don I would
hate I would I would hate to see that
for him it may would make it Tommy that
comes out last I think was last New
Year's Eve he's wearing this really cool
like tartan dinner jacket with the black
grosgrain shawl collar a you know collar
anywheres no bowtie white shirt open no
bowtie that's a fashion faux pas it's
against I had to look right down to the
last detail and then he blew it
it's a he broke one of stones rules that
would be a big Wow Wow
hey what did you think of I don't know
if you watched the George HW Bush
funeral yesterday but what did you think
of Donald Trump coming
he sat down at the funeral and
everything he sat with the former
presidents he shook hands with Obama he
shook hands with the first lady Michelle
and then Bill Clinton kind of looks over
at him no shaking hands with the
Clintons even though they were at this
funeral what did you make of that looks
me like they can't get over it that's
how I read that they just can't get over
it who can't get over it
the Clintons nice I mean I think the
president went the extra mile showed up
at the Rotunda to pay his respects
although I do think it's funny you see
like Eugene Robinson in the Washington
Post using the the the Trump army the
bush Sioux knurled to criticize Trump
we're talking about how Bush had respect
for the rule of law are you aware of the
fact that Bush invoked his Fifth
Amendment rights refused to be to
testify for the special counsel in
iran-contra nor we turn over any
documents whatsoever he pulled the old
Roger stone as it's called exactly yeah
read John Meacham's
book his biography you won't find that
anywhere now to read my book on the
bushes called the bush crime family
you'll find rich detail of that in worse
I mean I'm not going to use this
particular time timing is everything and
I think I had a great public service he
was very tenacious and very determined
he came back from early political
defeats become president United States
that's not easy he did it all with good
humor but we should not ignore the
atrocities of the Afghan war we should
not ignore the drug trafficking in
iran-contra there's a lot of blemishes
there not that I think it will happen at
all I'm not thinking it will happen I
certainly hope it doesn't happen however
what do you think you'd miss the most
about your life currently if you end up
going to jail well the only stripes I
look good in our pinstripes so and I
generally speaking don't answer
hypothetical questions I've broken no
laws in connection with the 2016
election or anything else this really is
a wedge gun I think I've been targeted
because I supported Donald Trump and I
helped defeat the Wicked Witch of the
West
you know Hillary Clinton but to take
your story literally out
now a good stake in a fine cigar would
be at the top of the list but not not
not a head of my family right right now
if my kids my grandchildren my dogs
that's the most important thing do you
think is there a possibility if again
purely hypothetical if you ended up in
jail would you maybe use your phone
privileges to stoke all in the show and
just let us know what's going on boy
there's a real hypothetical question
look if I'm charged I would plead not
guilty if I plead not guilty I will win
at trial I've done nothing wrong
this is a which one I mean what Brendan
Dassey thought the same thing you know
what I mean and and things happen you
know those West Memphis Three kids they
thought the same thing they just like to
listen to a little heavy metal music and
all of a sudden they're murdering
children according to turn this around
if I get framed in a railroad right guys
come visit me I will if you do the show
I mean if you call into the show still
I'll come visit you deal okay all right
if I get framed and railroaded and
unfairly convicted of something I didn't
do